monsieur fontanet le ministre de
l'éducation nationale a pris de décision
pour rendre les lycées plus humain et
pour un améliorer la gestion et la vie
dès la prochaine rentrée scolaire des
unités pédagogiques de 900 élèves
remplacement les lycées trop peuplé les
programmes de toutes les disciplines
obligatoires seront réduits de 10% ce
qui ouvre une petite porte aux
initiatives des professeurs et des
proviseurs une façon générale on peut
dire que les chefs d'établissement
auront plus d'autonomie plus de liberté
et d'autorité c'est le patron le patron
d'un grand lycée sous sa responsabilité
2300 élèves soixante quatorze classes
158 enseignants gestionnaire
administrateurs animateurs le proviseur
un rôle délicat à une époque où les
rapports humains sont difficiles à
maintenir surtout avec les jeunes
aux yeux des élèves ne représentons
quand même en gros l'autorité et les
jeunes sont les jeunes adolescents
d'aujourd'hui en tout ce sentiment de
révolte à l'égard de l'autorité qui
s'exprime d'ailleurs par un sentiment de
révolte à l'égard du père
ou à l'égard de tout ce qui touche
quelque sorte la hiérarchie de la
société mais je crois que bien souvent
lorsque j'ai eu l'occasion de les voir
je pense là j'ai une action avec eux il
peut se percevoir tout de même que je
suis là pour les aider il faut que le
profil le proviseur croit à son métier
croire à l'enfant croire en l'homme
croit aussi à la vertu de la parole
parce qu'il est devenu depuis quelques
années puis que jamais un médiateur
entre les diverses communautés
éducatives les les parents les les
élèves les professeurs l'administration
supérieure
c'est aussi un animateur un animateur
qui essaient de de secouer tout les
scléroses et c'est en fait un homme qui
se sent responsable de l'avenir
professionnel de ses élèves qui
cherchent surtout nos riantes heures qui
cherche surtout à les orienter vers les
sections qui offrent ou offriront le
plus les bouchers qui a la hantise de
faire les chômeurs oui mais comment
prendre contact avec tous les élèves les
problèmes le proviseur peut les
soupçonner il y a les conseils de classe
comme ici les dossiers mais 2300 élèves
2300 cas à considérer le lycée n'est-il
pas trop gigantesque l'établissement
dépasse un peu les normes humaine nous
préférons criante des unités
pédagogiques plus réduite
mais il s'agit essentiellement de faire
fonctionner l'équipe le chef
d'établissement n'est pas seul il doit
le savoir avant tout de toute façon nous
sommes beaucoup mieux enseigner que vous
ne le pensez sur les cas individuels
par exemple il m'est arrivé de recevoir
certains jours trois ou quatre coups de
téléphone de l'assistante sociale très
efficace qui me renseigne sur la
situation actuelle de certains élèves
des professeurs viennent me trouver
je convoque souvent l'élève
même pour l'interroger pour le faire
parler encore que le proviseur ne puisse
pas toujours intervenir personnellement
dans la mesure où ils représentent
l'autorité suprême et le père et il
risque d'avoir une réaction de révolte
il vaut mieux quelques fois qu'il passe
par une personne intermédiaire sur le
plan pédagogique par contrecoup sur le
plan financier nous souhaiterions un peu
plus d'autonomie en ce sens par exemple
que nous voudrions obtenir un contingent
global par exemple d'heures
supplémentaires qui nous permettrait de
renforcer les heures d'enseignement pour
les élèves les plus faibles dans
certaines matières d'assurer plus
souvent prolongement socio éducatif en
enseignement proprement dit nous
souhaiterions quelquefois aussi faire
éclater le cadre un peu rigide de la
classe peut-être une plus grande des
tonneaux autonomie pédagogique nous
permettrait de nous adapter aussi aux
situations locales à la figure à la
figure psychologiques ou économiques de
la région
c'est dans ce centre peut-être que nous
souhaiterions une plus grande autonomie